[Musik]
schön dass sie heute hier sind es gibt
vermutlich keine zeitgenössischen
architekten so viele sakrale bauten
errichtet wie mario botta über 20 davon
sind vollendet aber es werden noch mehr
in südkorea china israel der ukraine und
den nachbarländern der schweiz
mario botta sie sagen ja bauen sei eine
heilige handlung wenn man aber so ihr
pensum sich veranschaulicht dann ist es
erstmal sehr sehr viel arbeit haben sie
überhaupt zeit ihren erfolg zu genießen
jason los ob ich den erfolg und genieße
ich weiß dass war es erfolgt nicht
aber ich mag die idee die arbeit als
freude zu verstehen
nur ist für uns architekten diese freude
beschränkt denn sie dauert ja nur so
lange wie wir an einem bauwerk arbeiten
vollendet geht es an die gemeinschaft
und gehört nicht mehr dem architekten so
gesehen genießt man im nachhinein die
mühe und anstrengung die es brauchte um
zur definitiven lösung zu gelangen
das erschaffen selbst ist nicht immer
nur angenehm
es bringt viel mühsal mit sich und
erfordert enorm viel einsatz
nicht immer findet man gleich die
richtige lösung oft muss man sie
erkämpfen
ihr den schlaf opfern das ganze noch
einmal überdenken
[Musik]
während der arbeit kann man auch zu sich
selbst finden weil man so viele fragen
nachgehen muss die auftraggeberin eines
architekten ist immer die gemeinschaft
die öffentlichkeit die gesellschaft in
salla coletti vita die bauherrschaft
liegt in den händen der bürgerinnen und
bürger eines bestimmten historischen
zeitpunkt und es ist die aufgabe des
architekten diesem zeitpunkt richtig zu
interpretieren
er muss sich fragen was ist eine kirche
diesem moment was ein haus eine schule
es braucht also viel reflexion und die
lösung hat nicht nur angenehme seiten
sie erfordert arbeit recherche und
großem persönlichen einsatz
wenn sie jetzt aber zu beginn gesagt
haben ihn geht es sie mögen dieses wort
auch das erfolgs nicht im weshalb denn
auf die anderen punkte kommen wir sehr
gerne zurück zu jazz rally aktueller
mode erfolg ist eine sache der motor ist
eine mondäne äußerst vergängliche
ausdrucksform der heutigen zeit
mammographie mehr viel tiefer hingegen
geht das gefühl der anerkennung nicht
des erfolgs wenn klar wird dass das werk
richtig interpretiert wurde
und der architekt so mit seiner arbeit
entsprechend seiner zeit richtig gemacht
hat
gewinnen die lotto toto zu lavoro mit
probiotik boom
der architekt muss die arbeit die der
allgemeinheit von ihm verlangt aufgrund
seines historischen zeitpunkt
interpretieren
in unserem privat das ist nicht immer
einfach es ist nicht einfach die eigene
zeit richtig einzuschätzen
es kommen zweifel auf die unsicherheiten
und widersprüche die die eigene arbeit
anspornen und bereichern aber auch
schwächen können im moment da reagiere
manke in die bol ihre papiere auf diese
weise kann man die komplexität in die
widersprüchlichkeit der zeit in der man
lebt spüren und zu verstehen versuchen
tradition in der protein und klar weil
es ja so schwierig ist und weil es ja
zuvor auch beschrieben haben wie viel um
wie viel das auch von ihnen selber
kostet jetzt auch persönlich habe ich
mich gefragt weshalb nennen sie denn
bauen eine heilige handlung oder worin
liegt genau dieses heil
die aktuelle konstruktion in apathie
malachit nicht der architekt verleiht
einem bauwerk etwas heiliges sondern die
architektur der kunst der ursprung der
architektur liegt ja darin dass sie
einen natürlichen zustand in einen
kulturellen zustand verwandelt die erste
handlung bei einem hausbau ist nicht das
aufeinander liegen von bausteinen die
erste handlung besteht darin dass der
erste baustein auf den boden gelegt wird
und somit der natürliche zustand des
bodens zu kultur wird in modell zu allen
zeiten braucht der mensch ein haus er
brauchte eine zufluchtsstätte und muss
somit aus der natur kultur entstehen
lassen so gesehen bestehen die
heiligkeit in der ursprünglichen
handlung des bauens
der pakt jene des trimedialen der tote
ponys und dieses ursprünglich jetzt was
eben auch architektonisch ist das finde
ich interessant weil sie offenbar ja
auch in ihren träumen von architekten
besuch bekommen haben sie mal gesagt
habe ich mich gefragt worüber
unterhalten sie sich denn genau über
diese punkte die sie gerade erwähnt wenn
architekten unter sich sind führen sie
eher nüchterne gespräche
da geht es um die probleme des alltags
die schwierigkeiten ein kostbares
material zu gelangen
nein nicht in den träumen
ich kann nur schwer über träume sprechen
weil ich sie vergessen sobald ich
aufwache egal ob ich etwas schönes
träume oder ein albtraum habe am morgen
wache ich auf und beginne unbeirrt
meinen tag
ich schlafe wie ein kind
jahrelang und gerne schlafen ist eine
der schönsten tätigkeiten überhaupt
darum pflege ich meinen schlaf aber wenn
ich morgens aufwache denke ich an den
neuen tag der auf mich zukommt das finde
ich schön
nein ich denke nicht an meine träume
weder an die schönen noch an die
schlimmen das leben ist ein einmaliges
geschenk denn mit dem morgen verblassen
alle probleme des vortrags und der nacht
und man geht unbeschwert in den tag mehr
zumindest geht es so ein bleistift meine
arbeit verleihen mir ein gefühl der ruhe
auch wenn ich mal krank bin und mir mein
körper probleme macht setze ich mich an
meinen arbeitstag und schon geht es mir
besser meine medizin ist die arbeit wenn
du nicht wirklich schwer krank bin dann
hilft mir die arbeit bei der genesung
sie wirkt wie ein medikament weil sie
viel freude bereitet viel begeisterung
und leidenschaft mit sich bringt sie ist
ein unfehlbares heilmittel dass alle
schwierigkeiten aus dem weg räumt ich
liebe meine arbeit sie ist meine medizin
ich wollte es eben gerade fragen was sie
denn für eine beziehung zu ihrem
bleistift haben aber offenbar ist diese
beziehung eine medizinische der
bleistift ist eine art verlängerung des
gehirns er geht durch den arm zum blatt
und zeichnet er ist eine verlängerung
der
für einen architekten und für alle die
zeichnen bringt der bleistift die
gedanken zu papier
eine idee bleibt nicht abstrakt sie ist
nicht nur eine theoretische vorstellung
bei einem architekten verwandelt sich
die idee manchmal in einen zweifel oder
in eine ratlosigkeit
aber sie wird zum konkreten zeichner das
finde ich sehr schön mal die windows
sanofi sie kokos dem motto wenn das ist
interessant weil das heißt sie haben
nicht im vorfeld im geist schon ein ein
projekt sondern im schaffensprozess
inspizieren selber entsteht dass sie
immer so genau nicht alle architekten
arbeiten nach dieser methode aber für
mich ist die zeichnung eine suche ich
kenne das objekt nicht dass ich zeichne
ich suche es in den strichen und linien
die ich dauernd wieder ändere
es ist ein ständiges korrigieren und neu
zeichnen
ich brauche ein entwurf nur so sehe ich
die probleme und die menge die ich dann
laufend korrigieren
in einem architekturbüro habe ich kein
eigenes büro keinen eigenen zeichentisch
ich arbeite eine tischen meiner
mitarbeiter aus eresing tina die person
ja knapp 20 leute jetzt sind es etwas
weniger wegen der krise ich arbeite an
den tischen meiner mitarbeiter und
korrigiere laufend was ich vor mir sehe
ich brauche eine horizontale fläche vor
mir auf dem bildschirm der senkrecht vor
mir steht kann ich nichts korrigieren
man muss mir alles ausdrucken und wie
sie gesagt haben sind der bleistift und
die konkrete niederschrift eine
verlängerung der gedanke nicht dass ich
die fertige die schon im kopf hätte nein
ich habe nur eine ungefähre vorstellung
die sich in ständigem wandel befindet
erst beim zeichnen kann ich festlegen ob
es ein
kahles oder horizontales werk wird und
wie ich das konzept der schwere
einbringe die zeichnung ist eine suche
und keine darstellung gar noch präsenter
ziehen
aber das heißt auch für sie für ihre
arbeit sind die augen unglaublich
zentral das sehen da habe ich mich
gefragt was haben sie für einen bezug zu
ihren ohren gibt es auch so was wie in
der architektur sommers musikalische
harmonien weil zum es gibt ja schelling
oder oder schopenhauer zum beispiel die
sagen ja architektur ist so was wie
eingefrorene musik kann sie damit etwas
anfangen
sala definitionen
das ist schön gesagt jeder hat eine
bestimmte begabung eine vertrautheit mit
etwas für mich ist das visuelle die
grafische wahrnehmung viel stärker als
die akustische der musikalische ausdruck
die stimme das ist natürlich alles
vorhanden aber es ist ein wenig wie bei
der gastronomie oder beim wein
ich kenne mich da nicht besonders gut
aus man nur ökonomische ins emmental
maschinell aparte grafiker ganz anders
ist es mit der grafik jeder zeichen
strich führt mir die geschichte dieses
strichs vor augen ein abstrakter zeichen
strich erinnert mich an die abstrakte
architektur bei linien die ein konzept
nur andeuten kommt mir die chance in den
sektor schön gegliederte zeichen striche
bringe ich mit reid in verbindung
jeder mensch besitzt ein eher
beschränktes sprach register dato meines
beschränkt sich auf die visuelle
ausdrucksform von daher ist mir die
bildliche darstellung viel vertrauter
ist der klang von lima die nec genaue
zuordnung um noch einen anderen sinn
anzusprechen sie haben mal gesagt sie
sind mit dem geruch von lehen in der
nase aufgewachsen
jetzt sehen wir neben ihnen auch ein
ziegelstein hat das an eine auswirkung
gehabt konkret dass architekt wurden
dass sie da so nahe an diesem material
bellut vielleicht was sie sagen ist ein
schöner gedanke ob er der wahrheit
entspricht weiß ich nicht es stimmt
allerdings dass ich als kind oft mit
lehm spielte ich ging in eine
nahegelegene ziegelei und vergnügte mich
stundenlang mit lehm
vielleicht habe ich dort die wundersame
verwandlung eines erdhaufen in ein
ziegelstein entdeckt der dann zum
bauelement aber wirklich geprägt wurde
ich wohl anders er auf intellektueller
ebene mit 15 habe ich eine lehre als
bauzeichner begonnen
das war ein architekturbüro von ketteler
gallone und da habe ich realisiert dass
eine einfache linie auf einem bauplan zu
einer mauer werden kann desto besser
doch die winkte er ab
das war also das wunderbare aus simplen
linien in strichen können
dreidimensionale formen entstehen
da wurde mir klar dass das mein beruf
sein wird
also da was sie gelernt haben eben als
bauzeichner jetzt interessiert mich
natürlich sehr als architekt haben einen
speziellen bezug zum thema schönheit was
würden sie sagen oder was haben sie
inzwischen gelernt was schönheit
eigentlich ist es sowas wie purer zufall
reine geschmackssache ist es kann man es
berechnen ist es eine gabe also ein
geschenk was würden sie sagen ist
schönheit
meine antwort mag sie vielleicht
erstaunt
ich glaube nämlich dass jede form von
schönheit an ihrer zeit gebunden ist
[Musik]
wir können nicht sagen sagt das bildnis
einer schönen frau heute als gleich
schön empfunden wird wie vor 5000 jahren
schönheit ist also in verbindung mit der
kultur ihrer zeitepoche zu verstehen
neue serien der nostro
springen unserer eigenen zeit wir können
die schönheit von morgen nicht
abstrahiert was gestern war wissen wir
wir kennen alles bis heute aber morgen
werden die technologischen und auch
kulturellen sichtweisen die unsere
vision der welt bestimmen anders sein
als heute und sie werden unsere
vorstellung von schönheit beeinflussen
in der kunstgeschichte sind klare
schönheits vorstellungen definiert
weshalb wir sagen das ist schön weil es
zu seiner zeit als schön kalt
doch da ist dieses mysteriöse element
zeit dass die sicht auf die dinge
ständig verändert heutzutage zum
beispiel sehen wir bilder vom mars und
vom mond wir sehen neue landschaften die
wir bisher nicht kannten
wir müssen also lernen den zusammenhang
zu sehen zwischen dem was wir als schön
oder als hässlich bezeichnet und dem was
wir täglich neu entdecken
jetzt würde ich aber trotzdem sagen dass
ihr schönheitsbegriff wenn man das so
sagen kann ganz viel mit orientierung
doch zu tun hat sie haben auch mal
gesagt dass also und strikten symmetrien
vielleicht man könnte auch sagen
vielleicht ist es einfacher wenn man das
so zeigt wenn man auch sieht wie sie wie
ihre skizzen aus schauen sie haben mal
gesagt orientierung sei so was wie das
paradies und das chaos oder oder
labyrinthe seien die hölle
das heißt sie ein paradiesischer bauten
mein sohn ich will jetzt nicht über
meine arbeiten sprechen denn ich bin
voller widersprüche
aber die ausgeglichenheit der geometrie
ist mir eine große hilfe
sie hilft mir das gleichgewicht zu
finden
eine harmonie zwischen den einzelnen
teilen herzustellen
ich glaube dass man zum wohnen die
möglichkeit benötigt sich in einem raum
orientieren zu können
man kann nicht in einem labyrinth wohnen
ein labyrinth stiftet verwirrung
es ist voller widersprüche und kontraste
so ist doch das leben das ist doch das
wäre eine abbildung der realität oder
das leben ist ein labyrinth ein
labyrinth steht auch für vielfältigkeit
das stimmt aber der raum braucht eine
ordnung
ich glaube wer sich in einem raum
orientieren kann findet eine gute
wohnqualität der mensch bewohnt einen
raum wenn er in der lage ist sich darin
zu orientieren wenn man mit der
orientierung zurechtkommt wenn man weiß
wo norden und süden ist und auf welche
höhenlage man sich befindet dann fühlt
man sich wohl
denn dadurch dass der mensch mit der
natur und mit dem sonnenzyklus in
verbindung tritt gewinnt er an bedeutung
wenn ich ein einkaufszentrum gedreht und
mir die passagen wie irrwege vorkommen
dann fühle ich mich nicht wohl weil ich
mich nicht zurechtfinden
ich glaube der mensch braucht klarheit
damit er weiß wohin er geht und bis
wohin er gehen kann
maria dohmen um auf ihre frage
zurückzukommen
die geometrische ordnung ist ein
mentales schema dass unsere
lebensqualität verbessert den dank
diesem schema können wir uns orientieren
zurechtfinden und unsere position
bewusst wahrnehmen
für mich ist das sehr wichtig die leute
wissen es normalerweise nicht und sie
müssen es auch gar nicht wissen
aber die tatsache dass ich über meine
position entscheiden kann erhöht den
wert des monats weil das eben diese
orientierung jetzt für sie auch so
wichtig ist frage ich mich orientierung
hat auch mit proportionen zu tun
und der mensch besteht aus proportion
wenn wir etwa an den viktorianischen
mensch denken was würden sie denn sagen
ist der mensch und die proportionen des
menschen so was wie ein
architektonisches meisterwerk weil da
hätten wir dann schon so ein ideal das
sich fort zieht wo vito viano wie amin
der viktorianische mensch entspringt und
logischerweise eine theorie von vitos
der den menschen in den mittelpunkt
seines sein stellt und ihm so die
möglichkeit gibt sich innerhalb eines
raumes zu orientieren
mit seinen präzisen maßangaben des
menschen sagt vitruv genau das was wir
soeben etwas weniger präzise gesagt habe
das problem ist dass im kosmos ein
unendlicher reichtum steckt dem die
natur und check-in unsere aufgabe ist es
alles immer wieder auf menschengerechte
maße zurückzuführen
das ist ganz wichtig alle großen denker
und theoretiker genauso wie die großen
architekten und malers wir nur an piero
della francesca
er nahm die menschliche figur als
maßeinheit
für die perspektive in dem raum tiefe zu
verleihen
der mensch im mittelpunkt eine
menschengerechte lebensqualität
das sind die großen errungenschaften der
italienischen renaissance
sie bildeten den reichtum der mediterran
kultur die den menschen in den
mittelpunkt der veränderungen stellt das
leben bringt in diesem sinne bin ich ein
mediterraner mensch ich bin froh so nahe
an der grenze geboren zu sein wo ich den
mediterranen luft einatmen kann wo ich
diese kultur spüre nicht nur physisch
sondern auch mental ohne die erinnerung
an die vergangenheit kann man nicht dem
mediterranen raum leben die große
vergangenheit näher die gegenwart
ich möchte genau noch etwas die umkehr
umgebung von mario botta er besser
kennenlernen oder verstehen sie haben
zusammen mit ihrer frau maria ja drei
kinder die arbeiten alle bei ihnen im
büro auch und im film all telespazio hat
ihre tochter judith gesagt dass sie als
vater eben nicht oft da waren und dass
sie vielleicht hat architektur oder dass
sie haben architektur studieren müssen
damit sie überhaupt zu ihnen eine
richtige beziehung erhalten und ich habe
mich dann gefragt wie was empfinden sie
dabei die kinder schulden den eltern
nichts und die eltern schulden den
kindern nichts wenn meine kinder diesen
beruf gewählt haben dann war das ihr
entscheid hätten sie nicht gefragt hätte
ich ihm gesagt dass es ein sehr
schwieriger beruf ist er ist wunderschön
ja einmalig er erfordert unglaublich
viel leidenschaft aber er ist sehr
schwierig vielleicht hätte ich ihnen
geraten einen anderen weg einzuschlagen
aber kinder machen das was sie für
richtig halten
deshalb ist die berufswahl meiner kinder
nicht mehr zu
zu schreiben ich habe auch nie im
entferntesten daran gedacht eine
familien ja hier rund um diesen beruf
aufzubauen
ich bin mir bewusst wie schwierig die
arbeit des architekten heute ist es
braucht enorm viel energie und auch
enorme fähigkeiten und dem lebensraum
der menschen des 21 jahrhunderts zu
gestalten
ich weiß nicht mit der alltag der
zukunft aussehen wird
wie ich schon sagte ist es nicht einfach
die eigene zeit einzuschätzen
doch als architekt ist man gezwungen
hier und jetzt eine einschätzung zu
geben
wie ist die heutige vorstellung einer
kirche wie muss heute eine schule
aussehen wie gestaltet sich der wohnraum
in der architektur steckt die idee der
geborgenheit wie sie der mutterleib
bietet doch wie geht das heute man stößt
auch schwierigkeiten die jede generation
auf ihre weise überwinden muss ich weiß
nicht was meine kinder oder andere
architekten morgen sagen werden
ich versuche in der heutigen zeit die
organisation des raums so zu gestalten
dass er das heutige potenzial und die
heutigen widersprüche zum ausdruck
bringt mit dem corona virus hat sich
unser leben von einem monat auf den
andern verändert es hat uns neue
lebensbedingungen auferlegt und auch die
architekten mussten die lebensweise der
menschen auf dieser welt neu überdenken
und das kam völlig unerwartet
improvisierte prima vor ein paar monaten
oder vor ein paar jahren schienen solche
probleme in weiter ferne zu liegen
heute sind sie hochaktuell wir wissen
dass unsere widersprüchliche lebensweise
von früher nicht mehr möglich sein wird
jeder historische moment schafft ein
historisches bewusstsein und ideen post
sowie co-trainer change history und
trotz diesen ganzen schwierigkeiten die
sie auch nennen was was es bedeutet
architekt zu sein sind drei ihrer kinder
oder eben die ihre drei kinder
architekten geworden und sie selber
haben zuvor zwar gesagt sie schlafen die
ein kind aber wenn ich richtig
informiert bin schlafen sie haben gar
nicht besonders viel sie arbeiten sechs
tage die woche zehn stunden pro tag
arbeiten sie darf frage ich mich ist das
berufung oder ist das schon besessenheit
position ja es ist schon auch
besessenheit
denn in meiner arbeit finde ich ruhe als
ich vorhin von der arbeit als medizin
sprach meinte ich auch diesen aspekt der
inneren ruhe
es geht mir gut weil ich weiß dass ich
nicht nur für mich arbeiten das gefühl
der genugtuung das sich einstellt wenn
ich die richtige lösung gefunden habe
verleiht meine arbeit eine soziale
bedeutung gut zu bauen bedeutet auch die
menschen zu lieben so gesehen denke ich
dass ich meine arbeit mit kritischem
bewusstsein mit innerer ruhe und auch
mit ethischen grundsätzen ausüben
von daher
sie sagten vorher dass ich wenig schlaf
aber damit es mir gutgeht schlaf ich
mindestens
stunden schlafen gerne kommen wir noch
einmal auf meine kinder zu sprechen die
inzwischen natürlich längst erwachsen
sind und alleine zurechtkommen ich weiß
nicht wie sie mich sehen wie sie mich
einschätzen
ich weiß dass ich sie liebe und sie
lieben mich aber neben den problemen die
zwischen eltern und kindern bestehen
erleben wir auch einen tief greifenden
generationenkonflikt meine
weltanschauung ist ganz anders als die
meiner kinder
ich habe die künstlerische avantgarde
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts miterlebt
als picasso und die chance die szene
prägten weil es eine kopie sie und louis
kahn von sich reden machten
ich war noch ein junger und hörte ihn
begeistert zu oder gar zu ist da wo aber
für meine kinder ist diese zeit bereits
geschichte suggeriere dass bauhaus ist
geschichte für mich aber war das alles
hochaktuell moment politisch dann dann
schauen wir uns doch mal genau angeben
was sie aus diesem fundus den sie jetzt
gerade auch genannt haben genauso gebaut
haben sie bauen ja eben nicht nur
christliche gotteshäuser und architektur
sondern sie haben auch eine synagoge
gebaut und derzeit sind sie daran eine
moschee zu bauen in china ein schweizer
filmteam hat sie dabei auch begleiteten
wir schauen kurz rein sie
[Musik]
die bei canale sie basiert sondern
weltmeister
dann musst du musst gelb objektiv
mit beginn dieser lokale kommission hat
abbott man muss klug ihre medikamente
veronica pohl in samokow sie denn bella
lucio spielt die senior und die senioren
attraktionen islamisch orientale
großformat architektur viel interesse
der ekomi politiker solar die im
hintergrund war der salami inkasso.de
respekt orleans chemie der lintorfer die
brettorfer tutorial castro kommission
die programm in tudela muskelstärke
quando wieso die manifestation ivanova
bulgarien
[Musik]
nun haben wir auch gerade die kirche in
munio gesehen das war sozusagen der
startschuss für ihre beschäftigung mit
sakrale architektur und sie haben auch
oft gesagt den interviews sie würden am
liebsten nur noch sakrale räume bauen
warum denn weil ich im auftrag für einen
sakralbau jene tiefgründigkeit erkennen
dies in der profanen architektur nicht
gibt so erhält man aufträge für
einkaufszentren bürogebäude und
handelsflächen aber es fehlt die anfrage
nach sakralen räumlichkeiten mit ihrem
historisch geprägten hintergrund die
dentale die westliche kultur ist eine
sakrale kultur viola mehr gut meine
arbeit gründet auf der kirchlichen
kultur
angefangen bei mittelalter und abgesehen
von ein paar wenigen militär bauten
orientiert sich meine bildung an den
stelen am verlauf und einen formen der
kirchengeschichte
wir haben also einen moment in unserer
heutigen zeit der sich mit einer
jahrhundertealten geschichte
konfrontieren muss und das finde ich
sehr schön
louis kahn sagte die vergangenheit sei
wie ein freund tatsächlich kann man
sehen dass dasselbe thema mit wenigen
variationen seit 2000 jahren kaum
veränderungen erfahren
die kirche ist ein raum mit einem altar
und platz für die gläubigen die synagoge
beherbergt den torschrei auch dass eine
jahrhundertealte tradition
das islamische gotteshaus besteht aus
einem gebetsraum der nach mekka
ausgerichtet ist das interessante an
dieser kultur ist dass sich die werte
bis heute gehalten haben
vielleicht sind sie heute etwas
abgeschwächt generell hat kirche mit all
ihren problemen in einer weltlichen
gesellschaft wie der unsrigen ein
gewicht verloren
aber sie ist auch tiefgründiger geworden
die erhaltung dieser kontinuität ist
daher äußerst interessant sei es aus dem
gesicht winkel der form oder des raums
sei es aus theoretischer oder aus
politischer sicht denn ich bewege mich
nicht nur im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
ich folge einer tradition die von der
romanik über das reh nascimento den
barock das neunzehnte und zwanzigste
jahrhundert bis hierher reicht ich
befasse mich also nicht nur mit der
geschichte der architektur sondern auch
mit der religionsgeschichte und wenn sie
immer wieder auch diesen profunden
glauben an die architektur betonen
meilen sie damit genau das was jetzt
auch ausgeführt haben
ich denke dass jeder fest an seiner
arbeit glauben sollte man fragt mich
immer wieder nach meinem glauben
ich glaube an die architektur
die architektur ist der filter durch den
ich versuchen kann zu verstehen was
heutzutage eine moschee ist was eine
synagoge ist was in der heutigen zeit
eine kirche ist oder synagoge oder käse
denn im laufe der zeit hat sie vieles
verändert wir messen der religion heute
eine andere bedeutung bei als früher und
das ist
wichtiger punkt den man auch in der
geschichte der malerei beobachten kann
die malkunst des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts kann nicht getrennt von
jener malerei betrachtet werden die aus
der geschichte der menschheit entstanden
ist das toll um anita jetzt sagen sie
aber eben sie glauben an die architektur
und ich glaube ihnen das auch sofort ich
glaube auch daran dass gute gespräche
wichtig sind nur ist das was anderes als
ein religiöser glaube und wenn man sie
fragt was sie den glauben wir sprechen
hier von religiösen gruppen an
dann weichen sie oft auch aus hat er
seinen grund nein ich weiche nicht aus
ohne aber ich will die dinge nicht
vermischen so kritiker ich gehe das
thema mit kritischen bewusstseins
als ich am bau der kathedrale von avery
arbeitete hatte ich viele interessante
gespräche mit kardinal lustige ein
hochgebildeter mann ermahnte mich immer
wieder glaubens probleme nicht mit den
problemen der arbeit zu vermischen
das verstehe ich weil sie sagen auch
immer wieder eingedeckt muss nicht ein
guter gläubiger sein
trotzdem haben sie ja vermutlich einen
bestimmten bezug zum thema religion und
glaube ja sicher
ich denke ich bin auf meine art sehr
gläubig in den ausdrucksformen der
architektur suche ich nach den
ursprünglichen werten wie primo gerade
weil ich architekt bin weiß ich dass der
altar etwas völlig anderes ist als der
lesetisch für die tore das pult für die
tora lesung wie hier in tel aviv gebaut
habe er in der jüdischen tradition einen
großen ikonischen stellenwert aber es
dient einzig der lesung der thora
passiert nichts außergewöhnliches an
diesem ort literatur sowie eine um
faktor ist der ordinarius ich weiß auch
dass der altar in der christlichen
kultur weit mehr ist als ein einfacher
tisch er ist der ort wo die wandlung von
brot zum leib christi stattfindet die
christus interessen man zelebriert die
teilnahme an einem ritual bei dem die
gläubigen die zuschauen und zuhören zu
protagonisten werden
die tore für die präsente die wind die
protagonisten noch nicht so los ist
einer messe kann man nicht passiv
beiwohnen
die entweder ist man teil dieser
wandlung von brot zum leib christi
oder man gehört nicht dazu in den dax
ist unter die architektonisch gesehen
muss also dieser tisch je nachdem
unterschiedlich angegangen werden da er
in der synagoge einen anderen
stellenwert hat als in der katholischen
kirche das zeigt dass die tiefgründigen
ursprünglichen werte der drei
monotheistischen kulturen sehr
unterschiedlich sind und diese
unterschiede muss die architektur
hervorheben
in der moschee ich zu zeigen
china baue mussten wir alles umkehren
die islamische kultur ist mir fern
aber mir war bekannt dass sich die
gläubigen im gebet gegen mekka richten
bei uns in europa league mekka im osten
also richtet man sich nach osten
als ich in china war lag mekka im westen
wir haben dort in einem gewissen sinne
vertauschte breitengrade und auch der
sonnenzyklus verläuft anders
so ergibt es sich dass kleine dinge eine
andere bedeutung erhalten
hier muss der betende nach osten schauen
um mekka zu finden
in china schaute nach westen für den
architekt und bedeutet das eine völlige
umkehrung denn die sonne geht immer an
einer stelle auf und an der anderen
stelle unter aber in sie haben zuvor
etwas für mich sehr interessantes noch
erwähnt weil sie von der trans substanz
substantia zion in der katholischen
kirche römisch katholischen kirche
ausgesprochen haben und da interessiert
mich etwas ganz konkretes jetzt in
diesen in diesem gotteshäusern die
listen sie denn dass das ein ort wird wo
eben gott präsent wird wie sie es auch
zuvor so beschrieben haben oder wo das
heilige seinen platz findet weil ich
meine
anders gefragt gehen sie denn selber oft
in kirchen und wie empfinden sie das
nein für den architekten stellt das kein
problem da wir müssen ein einwandfreies
behältnis bauen den nach unseren besten
wissen und gewissen liter es ist wie bei
einer schule
ich baue das schulhaus in bester
qualität aber die lektionen die darin
abgehalten werden liegen außerhalb der
verantwortung des architekten die sich
auf 50 schaffen die voraussetzungen
dafür darum geht es ja genau
aber das mache ich bei der kirche
genauso wie bei einer bank austria ich
bin kein banker
trotzdem setze ich alles daran damit das
bankgebäude den bedürfnissen der bank
benutzer entspricht man darf die
funktion nicht vermischen mit aufgabe
der architektur ist es eine mögliche
interpretation der funktion des gebäudes
vorzuschlagen
aber es muss viel tiefere werte
enthalten
wenn ich eine romanische kirche betrete
die vor 1000 jahren gebaut wurde
spüre ich die ursprünglichen bedingungen
und werte die den romanischen
architekten beeinflusst haben ich fühle
sie als wären sie noch im raum
sie sprechen mich an wenn ich eine der
vielen hässlichen quartiers kirchen am
stadtrand betreten die vor wenigen
jahren erbaut wurden spüre ich nichts
von alledem ich glaube daher dass die
wahren tiefen werte auch von der
architektonischen qualität abhängen
es ist ganz ähnlich wie bei guernica von
picasso das werk macht uns betroffen
weil es an guernica erinnert liegt weil
es war picasso stammt er konnte uns
damit die botschaft vermitteln dass die
menschen sich nicht gegenseitig töten
soll
so will vater es gibt entscheidende
momente deren starker ausdruckskraft den
menschen in seinem inneren berühren und
an seinen prinzipien und werte
ich glaube dass die architektur dazu
dient ihre zeit zu überdauern
damit sie mit den kommenden generationen
kommunizieren kann
das ist jetzt fragen was sie sagen weil
zuvor wenn man als wir über schönheit
gesprochen haben haben sie ja gesagt es
gibt kein quasi ideal das für immer
bleibt und trotzdem sprechen sie jetzt
von der romanischen kirche die sie eben
berührt wo sie diese werte um zweiter
spüren was glauben sie denn wie wird das
mit ihren kirchen seien in 1000 jahren
naja in 1000 jahren die moderne kultur
ist sehr vergänglich die wird es dann
nicht mehr geben
ich weiß nicht ob sie so lange bestehen
werden aber um noch einmal auf die
romanik zurückzukommen
wir spüren heute das damals sehr starke
materielle werte herrschte inwieweit
diese religiös zu interpretieren sind
entscheidet jeder für sich selbst ist
ihm und diese werte sind noch da sie
sind in diesen kirchen die zeugen ihrer
zeit sind manuva darin olver nodari die
wallonie ich spüre dass diese bauten den
menschen damals die ikonischen werte
vermittelten die sie brauchten und die
für sie so wichtig waren und wir spüren
sie heute noch
die geschichte der architektur ist auch
die geschichte der bleibenden werte von
den kirchen bis hinauf bis zur gaudi des
vergangenen jahrhunderts bis zu louis
kahn und den heutigen bauten die uns die
botschaft vermitteln dass auch der
bürger und die bürgerinnen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts ein recht
haben auf meditation die auf momente des
in sich kehren der geistigen andacht die
momente in denen alle probleme der
heutigen konsumgesellschaft in den
hintergrund treten
wir müssen auf diese zersplitterung der
werte und den unaufhaltsamen
werteverlust reagieren
ich glaube dass der mensch starke
bezugspunkte braucht so ein bezugspunkt
ist die gewissheit dass eine kirche
sicher auf ihren grundfesten steht weil
sie dem gesetz der schwerkraft folgt das
ist schließlich ein physikalisches
gesetz
dank der schwerkraft geht der mensch
aufrecht dieses wissen ist wichtig auch
wenn es nicht direkt vermittelt wird wer
gut bauen will muss den naturgesetzen
und dem gleichgewicht der natur mit
demut begegnen
[Musik]
einstein einstein hat dies als einer der
ersten erkannt als ein shuffle mündete
in der suche nach den werten der natur
nach der kraft und dem gleichgewicht der
natur wie libri er sprach von einem
mathematischen gesetz das die natur
stützt thematik so etwas ist doch
spannend zuvor haben sie gesagt dass für
sie architektur auch so was wie selbst
mitteilung fast schon selbsterkenntnis
glaube ich haben sie gesagt ist dass in
diesem prozess in diesem
schaffensprozess das was ihr leben und
das vermischt sich jetzt mit dem was sie
sagen ist auch die idee zum beispiel in
kirchen dass eben diese werte dass sie
diese werte darstellen und uns mit der
erinnerung an die vergangenheit
verbinden versteckt das richtig was
sollen die vergangenheit aber auch an
die gegenwart
die kirche ist ein immaterielles gut
dass den menschen zur verfügung steht
der mensch lebt nicht allein erlebt dank
einer gemeinschaft wenn wir also diesen
tempel errichten tun wir das in
anerkennung der tatsache dass die
menschen einander brauchen und dass sie
werte brauchen statt werte könnte man
auch gott sagen die das
gesellschaftliche leben der gemeinschaft
zusammenhalten
mega moolah lavita soziale aktivitäten
ich glaube an diese werte dieselben
finde ich auch in einem museum im museum
warum besuchen wir ein museum war wir
gehen da hin weil wir uns mit picasso
austauschen können wie gas oder cezanne
oder mit paul klee und im klees bildern
erkenne ich das kind in seiner naivität
diese erkenntnis vermittelt mir klee auf
intensive weise das ist der alltag tun
wird somit ist das museum eine weltliche
kathedrale die ihre botschaft auf den
werten aufbaut die uns die künstler
vermitteln werte die wir brauchen
ohne elektronische mediation und ohne
die hilfe von erzählungen in bildform im
fernseher
das ist interessant weil diese dieser
vermittlung aber trotzdem sie als
architekt ja machen jetzt wenn sie ja
gerade baut machen eine vermittlung von
von himmel und erde irgendwie oder also
weil da ein gebäude ja dazwischen steht
man könnte sich ja auch fragen deshalb
braucht es für die vermittlung
eigentlich zwischen himmel und erde eine
ein gebäude es braucht nicht unbedingt
ein gebäude
man kann seine spiritualität auch an
einem flussufer oder auf einem
berggipfel leben aber sie fragen warum
es wichtig ist ein gotteshaus zu haben
weil es nicht mehr gehören sondern der
gemeinschaft ein sakraler raum gehört
niemandem
er ist kein privateigentum privater
gerade seine kollektivität verleiht ihm
seine
das gilt für mich für sie für ihn und
für den freund genauso wie für den feind
in foto georg wie museen und kirchen
sind sehr wichtig denn es sind orte der
stille der meditation der reflexion und
des gebets reflexion die barriere
sie sind wichtig weil sie der
allgemeinheit dienen coletti wo jetzt
führen sie mich natürlich zu einem ganz
wichtigen punkt weil ich frage mich wie
es für sie ist in kirchen zu bauen in
einem europa wo kirchen hat doch viel
mehr umgewidmet ja umfunktioniert werden
um nicht mehr neue kirchen gebaut werden
also die die institutionellen religionen
werden zunehmend geschwächt
sie sprechen da viele konkrete probleme
an
aber meine antwort ist sie aber nein ich
habe 22 gotteshäuser gebaut kirchen
kapellen und noch kleinere bauten die
grabstätten und so weiter weil ich damit
beauftragt wurde
ich habe sie nicht erfunden
ich bekam eine anfrage ob ich in evry
einer stadt in der pariser banlieue eine
kathedrale bauen würde und ich habe sie
gebraucht
wir brauchen eine synagoge in tel aviv
und ich habe sie gebaut
es waren aufträge an einen architekten
und als solcher habe ich die geschichte
der heutigen zeit interpretiert
mir kommt kein besonderer verdienst zu
nur weil ich angefragt wurde aber die
tatsache dass ich angefragt wurde
bedeutet dass es zu diesem zeitpunkt
genau dieses spezifische gebäude
brauchte
vielleicht weil die früheren
gotteshäuser veraltet waren
das ist ähnlich wie mit den stühlen
das angebot an stühlen ist im moment
enorm ich habe berechnet dass zurzeit
tausende von stuhl modellen auf dem
markt sind
dabei setzt man sich immer auf die
gleiche weise auf einen stuhl
warum werden tausende von stühlen
angeboten
weil wir auch beim hinsetzen dem esprit
der heutigen zeit folgen
ich will ein objekt sehen in diesem fall
einen stuhl das dem esprit der heutigen
zeit entspricht 10
nicht nur den klassischen tournee stuhl
aus dem neunzehnten jahrhundert der
immer funktioniert hat und bequemer
schöner ist als alles was wir heute
produzieren
denn wir setzen uns auch mit den augen
wir setzen uns auch mit dem verstanden
wir müssen uns vergewissern können dass
auch das alltägliche objekt unserer
kultur angehört
die diana ab jene ana ostric tun das
kann ich verstehen aber ich kann den den
stuhl irgendwie noch nicht ganz mit der
kirche verbringen also sie würden dann
sagen wir brauchen eben die gebäude die
zu unserer zeit passen heißt das ich
glaube es ist wichtig gebäude zu haben
die die kultur die technik die bauart
und dem materialien unserer zeit
reflektieren aber dann eine andere frage
wenn wir jetzt bedenken
eine ihrer lieblingsstädte glaub ich
milano wo der turm in der mitte der
stadt steht ist auch so in wien zum
beispiel oder in münchen also wir haben
im zentrum der stadt wo dann wie wie
sony via diana sonne die straßen quasi
von diesem zentrum ausgehen haben wir
ein sakrales gebäude new york zum
beispiel ist nicht so gebaut
ich frage sie jetzt als architekt was
würden sie denn sagen was macht das mit
einer stadt noch ein sakralbau milano
nun mit einem 1000 jährige geschichte
natürlich gerade da liegt der reichtum
der europäischen städte alle städte
europas entstanden an der kreuzung einer
straße mit einem fluss wie eine
kathedrale oder eine kirche errichtet
wurde später ein theater und andere
verwaltungsgebäude und von hier aus
wuchs dann die stadt da möchte ich sie
etwas anderes frage warum gehen
touristen nicht die gebildeten reisen da
die das besondere suchen
warum gehen touristen so gerne nach
venedig tun ist da war wenn nicht sie
gehen nach venedig weise auf der suche
nach sich selbst sind venezia venedig
vereint in sich die gesamte westliche
kultur und ihr verhältnis zum orient das
wissen die besucher zwar nicht aber sie
gehen hin um sich selbst zu finden als
teil der geschichte der menschheit der
sie angehören
das heißt dass die große vergangenheit
genauso wie das neue ein bedürfnis
darstellt wir haben von der kirche
gesprochen
die große vergangenheit ist eine weitere
große abwesende in der zeitgenössischen
kultur der kultura contemporanea was
finde ich denn in städten die nicht so
alt sind nicht mich selber den jüngeren
städten fehlt diese geschichte leider
aus diesem grund besitzen der
europäischen städte diese starke
anziehungskraft weil sie viel mehr
reichtum bieten als der amerikanischen
städte die geschichte einer
amerikanischen stadt erreicht 200 jahre
zurück
europas städte sind jahrtausende alt wir
brauchen die große vergangenheit
sie stellt ein kollektives gedächtnis da
das wir brauchen und an dem wir uns
bereichern ohne große vergangenheit gab
es keine grossen zeitgenossen wie
picasso und die chance
wir uns einen picasso vorstellen wenn es
die arnecke die afrikanische kunst nicht
gäbe so sind salate nonne possibile und
das geht nicht
bindi daher kann man sagen dass die
großen meister der moderne der
zeitgenössischen kunst aus der großen
vergangenheit geschäft haben
das hat doch seine bedeutung vorab
delikt corsa wir sind fast am schluss
ich habe noch zwei fragen sie erstens
sind sie doch waren sie junior trainer
des fc klasse und was sind offenbar auch
immer wieder dort im stadion
nein nicht trainer nicht nein ich war
torhüter damals war ich 16
[Musik]
es war eine verpasste beruf und könnte
man sagen als ich mein studium in
mailand begann habe ich den fußball
aufgegeben aber ich habe immer gerne
gespielt ich liebte diese vorfreude auf
den sonntag wenn wir am junioren turnier
spielten dann geht man lieber ins
stadion als in die kirche am sonntag was
ich aber fragen wollte sie sie beenden
ja gerade auch das stadion von ambri hc
ambri piotta und da wollte ich sie
fragen ob sie denn auch sich vorstellen
können ein fußball stadion zu bauen weil
oft wird gesagt das sind quasi die neuen
tempel unserer zeit
bisher hatte ich keine gelegenheit hatte
ich wurde noch nie gefragt
ich würde wahrscheinlich aber es ist
sehr schwierig weil so ein stadion viel
zu wenig genutzt wird
dem modell user die zeit genutzt wird
steht in keinem verhältnis zum einsatz
den der bau eines fußballstadions
erfordert es steht wochen manchmal
monate lang leer und nach 90 minuten
spieldauer steht es wieder einsam und
verlassen
warum habe ich dann das eishockey
stadion gebaut
aus demselben grund aus dem ich auch
kirchenbauer das eishockey stadion von
ambri ist der tempel der leventina die
leventiner war ein armes tal und seine
kathedrale war das eisstadion
juli so sind die als mir das projekt
vorgestellt wurde habe ich begriffen
dass die fans des hc ambri piotta ihren
tempel brauchen
abgesehen vom sportlichen aspekt spürte
ich dieses archaische ländliche
bedürfnis ein zeichen zu setzen
das tal forderte sozusagen seine präsenz
in der heutigen sport kultur natur das
positive die orgie mal wollte mainz
jetzt schon so es expressiv geworden
sind können sie noch zeichnen wie war
das heutige gespräch für sie in einer
skizze gerade gestern war ich in munio
weil der mexikanische botschafterin also
die aus bern die kirche in munio
besuchen wollte da habe ich sie
begleitet also zu ihrem mann immer mit
der idee eines platz aus glas
die metro das sich dem berg
entgegenstellt geschick untergrund
risiko für unter koller montana queen
die uni der die das dach dass die
interne struktur nicht zudeckt sondern
offen legt es enthüllt das geheimnis der
ellipse der oft nach höhe in einen kreis
übergeht
diese kirche enthält eine geometrie und
ich habe die geometrie offengelegt der
deutsche kritiker rudolf arnheim der in
den 1930 er jahren nach amerika
ausgewandert ist fragte mich in einem
brief stimmt es dass sie das zentrum der
kirche so angelegt haben das in der
senkrechten der kopf und jesus darin
erscheint dieses detail hatte ich nicht
gedacht aber er hat es gesehen
[Musik]
das zeigt dass ein architekt manchmal
dinge tut die er gar nicht kennt
wir haben hier versucht den rationalen
technischen sinn der motivationen
auseinanderzunehmen
aber oft lässt man sich auch von
intuitiven motivationen leiten
ich danke ihnen
vielen dank für dieses gespräch wir
wollen sonne statt reagan sang er 1980
erklärte einem toten hasen was kunst ist
und strich fed in ecken von
ausstellungsräumen joseph beuys dieses
jahr sollte der künstler seinen
hundertsten geburtstag feiern
bossert geht dem phänomen boys nach im
gespräch mit philip ursprung jetzt
gleich einer sternstunde philosophie
bis bald
[Musik]